Let me start by saying there is no
greatest movie of all time.
The question is just too difficult to
really answer,
but I still think it's the most
important question in cinema.
What makes a movie great?
There are a number of concrete aspects
of a movie that turned them from good
movies to movies with the legacy.
The first is cinematic influence.
How did the movie changed the way movies
are made?
If you read anything about citizen Kane,
you'll realize that it's probably the
most innovative movie of all time and
that's a big reason why a tops every all
time.
Movie List Citizen Kane highlights a
very clear distinction between two areas
of filmmaking,
especially in it's cinematography.
Silent films were very economical with
their editing.
They either showed their actors on a
simple two dimensional plane or used
montage cuts to quickly associate one
idea with another,
and one sound was introduced in the late
19 twenties.
The first instinct for many directors
was just filming dialogue,
shot,
reverse shot with shallow focus,
and it was boring.
Here's your price
on it,
or a steven from the hands of the lady
who was a blackout on today.
That's my quote.
I've lost results,
our guy,
but Orson Welles and Gregg toland
changed the game in 1941 by bringing
back traditional theatrical staging onto
the screen.
The use of deep focus camera allowed
characters to be staged in interesting
and revealing way.
You are the sole owner showing power
dynamics,
transitions of power,
complex visual storytelling,
and giving the viewer active
participation in the seed,
allowing the viewer to choose what to
look at.
Instead of having a close up force you
to watch one character at a time.
Wells and tollens weren't the first to
use this technique,
but they executed it so effectively that
they started a movement.
Yeah.
Iconic,
deep focused and sharp lighting.
A film noir,
movies all influenced from citizen Kane,
not to mention,
well,
his use of sound to transition from one
scene to another,
which is basically in every single movie
now,
not to mention the makeup which had
never been done so extensively.
Not to mention it's extensive use of
flashback and unreliable narration,
which had only been done majorly in
literature.
Once you think about it,
there's no question of its greatness.
Great movies change things.
Star wars ended a streak of dreary and
sophisticated movies in the 19
seventies.
The Blair witch project changed the
horror genre for good and it looks like
deadpool's going to change the game when
it comes to marketing a movie and we'll
probably see a lot more r rated comedies
in the future because of it.
If a movie changed what other filmmakers
we're doing,
it's got to be at least a little bit.
Great.
The second measure of greatness is the
cultural impact.
How did the movie change the actual
world?
It was made it not just the world of
cinema,
like when jaws made beach attendance
plummet,
or when fight club made an actual fight
club spring up around the US.
Personally,
I think if the movie fight club inspired
you to start your own fight club,
then you're totally misreading the
movie,
but that's a topic for another time.
All I'm saying is movies aren't in a
bubble.
Movies can make laws get enacted,
they can spread awareness on a massive
scale to billions of people.
The ones that catch the attention of
enough people are great,
even if it's just bringing back folk
music
was
the third and final way is personal
impact.
It's the way that movie changes you.
I think this is the most overlooked
aspect of a great movie because it's
hard to measure,
but I've always been a big believer that
movies can tell us more about how to
live our lives than the real world does.
I think Juno explores abortion in a more
accessible way than any abortion
pamphlet or any talk show host and she
was like,
oh,
hi,
babies have fingernails,
fingernails,
and I think that ability to tap into
reality through a story makes a movie
one of the greats,
and it's the underlying beauty of
cinema.
A movie doesn't have to change cinema
forever and it doesn't have to change
the world forever,
but if it changes you forever,
it's got to be pretty great.
I know this video is going more
sentimental than usual,
but greatness is hard to discuss
otherwise.
There's certainly measurable cinematic
techniques to judge for greatness,
but at the end of the day,
it's the way movies touched us
personally.
That makes them great.
People pick different movies as their
favorite because at that point in their
life,
that was the movie they needed to watch
to help them out or just to astound them
the most.
It could be as simple as a movie that
makes you laugh a lot.
I find that if I really liked the movie,
I think about it constantly after I'd
seen it 500 days of summer really helped
me with a bad relationship because it
felt like the movie was talking about me
and explaining everything I was
currently feeling so perfectly.
So how about this and normally terrible
at keeping up with social media,
but tweet about your favorite movie to
my twitter at swag thug for life and
I'll respond to it.
Let's talk about great movies and while
I did start by saying there is no
greatest movie of all time.
It's definitely the princess bride
pack,
which Tammy,
thanks for watching.